[Music]
what can you expect from the Portlandia
activity book well it's made by the very
good people at McSweeney's and they're
an incredible career talented group yeah
and this is kind of a hands-on kind of
do-it-yourself art book a do-it-yourself
art book crowdfunding your baby there's
one thank you your baby if you want to
open a B&B right right it tells you how
to do that
this is stuff that and and it also did
you not part of the inspiration was
people in Portland suffer from the fact
that what is it 364 days a year of rain
yeah that's about right yeah it's a
cloudy place yeah and so you have
activities in here for people when it's
raining constantly yeah
we have one I brought something along we
have something in there that's a
conversation starters and conversation
Stoppers okay so these are conversation
starters if you're like a Portland I'll
use the word hipster sure well if you're
important these are conversation
starters okay here's a conversation
starter a carry you do this one okay so
this might sound too forward
but could you foster these disabled cats
see right away you wanna engage
from Portland I want in on that yeah
there's one for you okay here we go
conversation starter lately Susan and I
have been going dumpster diving with our
son Charlie I go around and leave nice
things in there for us beforehand so he
will have something to believe in
I'll do this one here okay this is a
conversation stopper stop this is a
status stopper okay different reaction
okay um who are you dating I want to see
if it's the same person I'm dating that
would stop okay here's here's one for
you this is a definite stopper a stopper
I actually don't know who the Ramones
are that way that would get you probably
ends everything beaten savagely yeah I
wouldn't just yeah